this one looks just winning meanwhile in
the love game peter do you want to just
stick with this for a bit because it
might end soon exactly yeah i think we
should stick till the very end and then
we should also move on to to the prague
game against alideza
because
levon's game and also niman's game they
started uh
later yeah so we have to first watch
those games that are in real progress
yeah queen on the board he goes for the
most direct line and now rook c1 coming
in uh taking advantage of the back rank
peter that you've been pointing out on
the board um i think he has to come back
with the knight so he has to go knight
c3
oh my god that's a beauty
that is a stunning move uh peter
finishing the game with a checkmate
yeah yeah it's it's lovely of course
yeah magnus has force in it
those are those are giving so much
pleasure you had to finish a game like
this
let's just show the myths that would
have happened after sacrificing the
queen rookie one rook even